yeah welcome to this video and I'm
playing wooly Gus again this is great
you want to have two to easy Game Center
hopefully is a game Sanj and you played
this guy again if you watch the video
before you notice that he's playing
every position on time
look against rook and everything and we
am quickly again get an endgame here
where luck has some slightly worse
position he doesn't mind you see him he
just plays every position on time and
doesn't really care about the chest so
let's see me let's see what what happens
here
yeah he has some equalised him in the
Sun descent game this line is some is
really a problem for white in terms of
getting any anything in terms of an
advantage I play this line myself as
black and I really don't know what to do
against it so this doesn't look like
great play from white but I I don't
really know what to do so I mean I don't
know what to want to play in order to to
to give black a harder time than I'm
actually doing right now this kind of
position is some very slightly more
comfortable for Wyatt
but it's nothing yeah nothing to write
home about really just a second
in this time can try to close the door
to get rid of some of the background
noise okay so we have this position ISM
probably still about equal it's not much
happening
Yahoo c5 was a possible idea okay
younggook rookie to try to invade there
so I better prevent that yeah in general
there's not much happening
he cannot advance the deep own I can
just take it this I'm surprised about
why would you allow me to play up c6 I
just get get the square now check
yeah this is just leads to to a slightly
worse and gainful like chant isn't it
yeah what slightly versus some putting
it mildly
I just get get this porn okay can I can
also just push him Becky him and now he
gets to be seven maybe this wasn't so
great okay but I can I can cover g3 and
support from the side it is a threaten
that and now I can use the King Kimmie 6
h 5 King f6 h 4 hmm
each voyage fire hmm
yeah it's a bit of a problem I thought
I'm I just enter him
you had a midlife life really hard for
me here - the Phantom
it really is easy game and no it's it's
not so easy at all hmm
YUM I spoiled a spot this already
check game Quran yeah yeah I had ad I
just look it's heaven was terrible I
just need to take a five here this is
much better on ob6
I don't know have round here I I spot
this can't be five what he played was
just very bad or here Rukh is heaven
takes h7 maybe this is the the cleanest
way to do it h-hi yeah everything's good
but what's the best one
I don't know this it can't be too bad
you're in it so let's let's check him
check King c6 of course King c6 yeah I
just I wanted to take the pawn badly but
King c6 is much better threatening mate
and I get get here this is very strong
very strong let's say something like
this I just have this super active kick
now and this pawn I cannot defend anyway
look a to h7 is completely dead he
actually probably has to play this one
yeah yeah okay and this is this is
really easy like this and somebody a d4
c1 let's say here blocking the king and
yeah this is this is quite easy I also
have this additional idea to get another
Passport yeah this would have been much
better the way it played out I don't
think I could have done much
turn at least after this-here here must
play differently I I just thought okay
group III I take item I approach with
the King but I forgot about the h4 h5 h4
idea which is of course a bit
embarrassing because it's the only idea
that black has so here G form I must
play G for him and probably still I'm
better yeah this makes the draw I mean I
wanted to to secure that man mmm
it's just something else add this I can
play I can play that I hope got about
that here this is this I can do after
this rook here with this idea if he
takes it's a check and I threaten the
threatener friend here hmm
yeah this was strong yeah so I missed
many chances in this game many chances
but ok here was already a bit unnerved
because if you have watched the game
before you know it that he plays rook
against rock on time and so on
ok so I I thought that I saw this line
leading to a dead draw and I took it not
the best choice of course alright thanks
for watching